Vince said the most cursed thing was cursing so far today to me yeah all right would you like to share in the class what did he just said to me before we swap the screen what do you like I said I hope Carfield is good and then I said don't fuck the cat and would you like to elaborate what you said right after is having a field.
He's getting real excited.
He's getting any Jay Dawson's in chat looking forward to Garfield showing up.
All the contributions to the site is him.
He's like 99% of the rule 34 and then the 1% is AI.
Hello everybody.
Hi.
Hello.
Welcome to Rule 34.
So before...
Oh wait, what you're gonna say.
No, you go.
You go.
No, no, no.
You go first.
I was gonna say, okay, nobody is gonna believe me when I say this, but I don't think I've been on the Rule 34 website before.
Yeah, because she has other sites that she needs.
I go on Dom Boru.
The weak equivalent of her.
It's a little...
The site is full of animators.
Okay, it doesn't make it any better than all humans.
You just specifically look for like rule 34 of anime characters.
You're like trying to be more specific to weeding out the non-weeb shit.
Like, yeah, I mean, it's not so easy to check.
Isn't it more degenerate than rule 34?
Because they have more tags in it.
And they don't know.
I've never been on rule 34.
They look into like, they look into like all like the Asian websites.
too because rule 34 mostly look at the western side so like you know they dig deep yourself on donboru no did you that don't i'm gonna look you up right now donkey bird i bet you saw something something freaky is there yeah how freaky how freaky let's see okay it's really funny because Let's see your tags.
The first one is indie virtual youtuber and the second one is gamers
So I knew mint would be the perfect duo For this stream because she is like I said freak phantom She would have the knowledge the knowledge for this and for so um wait.
Yeah, you gotta tell me tell you what Go ahead No, you go first.
Okay, okay, so, so when we were talking about rule 34 dope, she thought we were actually gonna look at real porn and anti on my channel.
And she was like, oh, it's on Jokey's channel, so I don't have to worry about it.
And like, yeah, she's risking her own channel.
I thought you were gonna have like a crazy sensor ready or something.
like, did you not open, by the way, we arranged this collab like, what, a week and a half ago?
And I was like, you did not look at the website at all for a week and a half?
You played this.
What?
What game?
What's the what's the game?
Honey Pop!
You played that.
I played it on Steam!
That's the censored version!
It's a censored, I know!
Oh, what do you mean?
What do you mean it's not censored?
What do you mean?
Oh, you've seen a lot more.
Oh, you seem to know a lot of what's on that phone.
You'll see.
You'll check out what's on my phone, right?
It was not censored.
I played the Steam censored version.
I don't know what you're talking about.
But yeah, she thought we were actually going to look at...
We're actually going to look at real Hentai important on my channel.
She was very disappointed when she found out it's just Wordle with rule 34.
This is not even Wordle though.
It's just pick the character.
It's higher.
Okay, so for those who don't know, it's higher or lower, but with rule 34 tags.
So so we're given two options here right now.
Sailor Jupiter or Fox McLeod.
we have to decide which which has more porn in the their tags i like how also doki was like oh you are you are equipped for the stream because you collect dojin oh yeah i was like you actually own r18 like hentai and dojin's i own hentai yeah you look like you own
Oh, my dog agrees too.
Yeah, that's that freak right there.
That's her.
I forgot.
I need to feed him real quick.
You can all be right back.
That's why he's barking.
Dad agrees.
Wait, guys, Doki said that she owns one R18 Dojin.
Only one, which is unheard of for me.
I have a whole book show.
full of thin books but does anyone know what she owns what is it what is it okay what what were you asking my chat without my consent huh is it okay i'm gonna guess is it is it robot themed no damn okay so yeah i told her i own one dogen and only one because it was a pair and I was so desperate for any type yeah it was a it was a rare pair and I was so desperate to consume any content of this of this pairing because there was like there was actually like practically none except for like one to two very overzealous yes I was a I was an ex Fujo so there was a really dark times for me but i was sonic what would it be sonic i'm just wondering what i had a very dark history with that with with male x mxm bl uh shipping and there was one rare pair that i could never get enough content of because it was so rare and such a obscure fandom and there was only like one to two i think like japanese artists that would draw this pairing and i would buy every i would like i even to the point where i
don't know like were you a tumblr user back then or no no okay so back down tumblr these artists they'll have like alternate like r18 art blogs and you have to find their password and everything in their blogs and like because it's like hiddenly locked in behind a r18 tumblr blog and then you got to find the so yeah and then you have to find the r8 like the password in their regular art blog because it'll be hidden in there and they'll like make it like invisible text and everything so you have to do like detective mystery work to to access the porn like what why are they gatekeeping why are they gatekeeping and then so so it was like my only way to consume to consume my rare pair so it's it's the one dogen i own the i purchased like that i purchased is the three kingdoms um it's from it's it's i didn't see war here No!
What?
He don't understand.
He's just a one, one pairing that kind of seaworthy.
Because like, okay,
I- Why would you, why would you say his love?
Oh, did I hit the nail on the head?
No, no, it's not.
It's a, it's a rare pair.
Oh, sorry, sorry.
Look, I will say, look, if they had enough content, I would never have stooped.
I would never have, like, actually bought the Doge in, but, like, I was desperate.
Like, you don't even see it, barely see any even fanfictions of, in general, Dynasty Warriors pairing still.
Like, you don't even see, like, a lot of fanfictions about it.
So, like, if I could, because I was a fan of, you know, other characters, you know, you know that would be a you know that would like that would make my food your side happy but this particular fandom it made me sad so i had to it made me really sad and i was starving i was so i was so hungry did you write fanfics of them because they had nothing i i think i like did it i okay okay so you know do you remember live journal oh so in live journal they would host these things called those anonymous kink fan fiction or so i don't remember what it called do you remember those i don't remember what they're called i hope that they would people would request like there to be like we're so starving you post anonymously and you have to post anonymously you can post anonymously I'll be like looking for this Harry doing this and the writers would like break oh yeah the cake memes yeah the cake memes that was what they're called look it was I was very deep into it because like I was so hungry.
I Needed an itch that needed to be scratched.
Okay So I've learned something I was so desperate because it was all my other favorite ships I was fine.
I was satisfied.
There's so much iron of it I can consume it and everything but this one this one was where I had to cross the line and actually own Do you still have it?
I do, I found it like, like, I think like a couple of months ago.
And I was like, oh my God.
Yeah.
So the rare pair, I don't even know.
I don't think you know the characters.
That's how rare they are.
Cause they only show up for, in the newer games.
And like, cause it was like, cause it was like, they were like, they hated each other.
And I'm like, oh my God, enemies to lovers.
Oh no, wait, you're describing what I do.
Oh no.
So it was for people in Shagu, actually know the dynasty warriors uh fandom or like the game it's sima dao x juke dan so that was the pairing i'll show you the characters okay show me how outstanding like look at them look look at them look at each other oh look at them look at each other that's what i'm saying this is perfect enemies enemies the lovers.
Hey, Doki, do you know a game called Metal Gear?
Did they look like Metal Gear Couple to you?
So, this is who they are, chat, but I don't know why.
Look at them!
Look at each other!
Okay, chat, look at this photo and tell me the right is not us a lot and the left is snitch.
I see it.
Do you tell that they're looking at each other with love?
The exact thing.
There's so much love right now.
They look the exact thing.
Why am I also seeing Virgil on the rock?
Virgil!
I'm self-inserting, not self-inserting, I'm inserting every character.
You're like, I see it.
I understand.
I understand now.
Yowie is a circle.
Yeah, it's a BL.
is a circle it's basically the same care the same personality but like for different characters
so so this is the one dogen i own that's actually still in my apartment right now i want to see it yeah i'll show it to you later i'll show you i'll show you the the good parts
This is Min's audio.
Okay, so far.
Am I good?
Yeah, is she good?
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
Blah, blah, blah.
All right, let's...
Okay, all right, so...
We talked about this a little bit.
There's no BGM.
I don't even know if we should have a...
Should we have a BGM for this?
I don't even...
Maybe some, like, pee-pee music or some pee-pee...
What's this one in the background?
I don't even know.
Okay, let me grab some music real quick, guys.
Let me use my usual playlist.
Yeah, like a saxophone, like a sexy BGM.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, wait.
Let's see.
Saxophone copyright free.
All right, saxophone music, no copyright.
You like jazz?
Yeah.
All right.
Oh...
They can't...
Okay, wait, let me...
Let me make it so they can hear the chads real quick.
Yeah, you like that, but you don't like it.
Yeah, yeah, keep that one, keep that one.
They weren't able to hear it earlier, so they don't worry.
It's doing something for me.
Ooh!
Whoa!
Oh!
your Fujo Club meeting right now.
Oh, we're saying it's seabat.
We're setting the moon.
All right.
Oh, yeah.
So we had a little discussion about this a bit before the stream started.
Wait, what if we just put seabat on repeat?
What is that?
Is that that going to get copyrighted?
the hat that's probably good yeah that's probably wood yeah are you guys in the mood guys is this putting in the mood yeah in the in a hot freaky mood right now you ready to get your free dog chat oh yeah oh yeah oh wow i'm getting into it
I feel like this is this is sacks Seabat Sacks upon Seabat Yeah Sound guys Is the PGM loud enough so that we can all get freaky tonight Like Whoa Oh they can't hear it don't worry Oh there's lyrics How is he saying What is he saying?
I don't know
You and I are working here today Yeah.
But I don't know.
Is it sexy talk?
Is it?
What is this?
Don't turn it up so I guess like don't turn it up too much guys.
All right, out of this.
I just
realized it's literally just one chord and they repeat.
It is just one thing and they repeat.
No thoughts, just vibe.
Alright, is that good enough audio testing sound, guys?
We're just vibing the music now.
All right.
I think it's Fox McLeod.
I think it's Fox.
I honestly think so too.
Like, we talked about it before because we're like, even though, like, yeah, Sailor Jupiter has been around for a while.
So has Fox, though.
So has Fox, yeah.
And also, like, furries love their porn.
It's Fox for sure.
Wait, wait, wait.
Before we starve, what do you think our streak is going to be?
Our streak, I would be surprised if we get to 10.
My streak.
I think 10 is a good goal.
Yeah, 10 is a good goal.
Because, like, the furthest I got to was, like, three.
That was the furthest I got to.
But, yeah.
Fox.
Oh, my God.
That's a lot.
What the hell is she?
She's from Bleach.
She's, like, the main girl in Bleach, right?
Is she the main girl in Bleach?
Who is she?
It's Fox.
I still think it's Fox.
fox is gonna go on for a while until we get to like genshin or some shit if if sailor jupiter only had like a thousand i still think it's fox yeah also i think if i think if it was like sailor moon then i would believe she would have a fighting chance but like yeah yeah yeah yeah also but orihime has big boobies a majority of anime women have big boobs though yeah doesn't mean like you know like sometimes you know if we get over saturated it with big boobs like sometimes you can get bored of that you know that's why variety is nice so not not not sometimes you want a fox yeah sometimes you yeah sometimes you know including more spice in your life maybe a fox ain't too bad people are saying copium oh oh that's close That was close though.
That was really close.
What if...
What is Mushoku Tensei?
Isn't that... That's um...
It's a entire franchise though.
The dungeon.
That's uh...
Mechi.
Wait, isn't that dungeon?
Okay, there's a lot of Isakai shit.
I don't...
I don't... I think it's...
Is that a whole franchise though?
Yeah, but like what is that though?
To be fair, I don't know a lot, but...
Oh, it's not dungeon Mechi.
I'm a stupid.
Yeah, it's really said Mushoku...
Tensei, not Dungeon Meshie.
What?
Sorry, I'm jet lagged.
The title is right here.
What do you...
I don't know.
I was just looking at the picture.
Someone said it's the Isakai.
It's a fairly new...
It's the Isakai?
Oh, Mint doesn't even know it.
She's got to revoke her...
Weep card.
She doesn't even know it.
I don't...
I don't watch anime.
share all right all right no okay okay or he may one eclipsa butterfly who the hell oh that's from star versus okay i she does have i know she does she is okay let me okay but she is popular in star versus the fourth she's like she's like the goff queen basically really yeah she's like i thought this site would only have anime no it's like It's like there's even VTubers in there.
Yeah.
Someone got you while they're playing this game.
Wait, check, you know, check my waiting room Twitter and look at who got you.
I'm looking.
Yokey bird.
Wait, you're at the tweet?
Yeah, the waiting room tweet.
And see, look at who got you while they were playing this.
Yeah.
You saw it?
He showed up on KU's and run.
Sorry, Kay.
And then he closed, and then he closed the game.
He closed.
Oopsie.
Oh.
my god but yeah we don't know wait did you see the other thing someone said they put this in the daily challenge and it's me for a sissy yeah really no
way all right i think it's musho kutensei i don't think they have a big enough fandom yeah i was just 544 yeah yeah oh dad
is showing my children is yes that's a that's for kids No, no, no.
So is Star versus forces of evil to be fair?
No!
Oh, no!
No, no.
Oh.
I know.
Like, the parents may be.
Okay, so, okay.
Because it's the entire series.
I'm just a five-width series.
Nothing else, but nothing else.
I would say that Blue is a very...
That's horrifying.
That's a horrifying...
That is so...
Yeah, there's...
No!
We have to make a choice that is higher than lower.
You know what, man?
Who do you think has more rule 34?
Don't put this on me!
I don't know, man!
I don't know!
I don't know either!
What choice should we make?
I think maybe in times of hardship we go with the furry buff.
That's true.
No matter what the property is All things point to furry
Always bet on furry and Pokemon Like they say There's no rules against Pokemon Batman And apparently the Bluey 2 There's no rules I was like, if there's no laws, it gets bluey, Batman.
Oh, at least it's not showing us what's in there.
There you go.
3,000.
I hope it's...
Okay.
I will assume...
Okay, I think we should quit.
It's bluey, we're just going to quit.
Okay, if bluey...
If Bluey has more Rule 34 than Okayu, then I would be very sad.
Oh, we're going to lose our streak.
You're going to pick Bluey?
You're still going to pick Bluey!
I think Okayu because I think...
Well, actually, I don't know how many people use this site.
Like, how many people are...
This...
How active is Rule 34?
Yeah, we removed AI.
Rule 34, right?
Yeah, it's not Danburu.
It's Danburi.
What's it called?
Yeah.
Oh, Danburu.
Danburu.
It's not Danburu.
It's Rule 34.
We have- I don't know how active this site is.
It's not Western fans to overpower Bluey.
Oh, apparently it's a very Western site.
Oh, God.
Oh.
I...
Are you really gonna continue on with Bluey this year?
Do you have faith in the power of VTubers?
Or do you think the furries win?
I'm going to let you pick this one.
Wait, why did I pick this one?
I picked the last one.
No, I also agreed with you.
I began.
So it's your turn to make the pick and I'll agree with you.
You're the representative for VTubers.
Okay, let's go with Okayu.
Let's have hope.
We're already five anyway, so.
I told you.
What do you mean I told you?
I said you make the choice and I'll agree with whatever.
Because I didn't want to believe.
Yeah, you're a coward.
You're a coward, man.
You're a coward.
You couldn't pick Bluey.
You knew in your heart it was Bluey.
It's over.
So it's like never bet against the furries.
Well, I didn't.
Let's see.
Well, we got halfway to what our goal was.
Yeah, yeah, we got halfway.
That's...
Um...
Okay.
Okay, look...
Mona is very popular, but so is...
But Miku...
Miku has been around longer.
Yeah, I say Miku.
But are they more strong...
Are they stronger than the power of Genshin, though?
I think Miku still, I think Miku.
You think so?
Miku, sweet?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, that's a lot.
I'm sorry, but...
I'm sorry, you're up against Meeku.
Why are all these weirdos going on?
Where did they all direct it?
They knew.
They're like, on Saturday, Doki and Min are going to rule 34, though.
And they changed the algorithm.
They changed the algorithm.
Because, like, when I was testing it up, I did not hit any VTubers.
And even though my longest stream was three, I did play like four times.
But this one's easy.
It's also Kanata.
Yeah, it should be.
112.
That's pretty good.
That's actually more than I thought.
Oh, wait.
The entire.
You think Kimei's going to win the entire franchise of My Hero Academia?
I think.
No.
Maybe not.
What's that one girl?
The girl that can flow?
I think she alone has.
Or no.
I think it's the, you know that guy, the perverted guy that everyone hates?
I think he has more than Hime.
Oh.
I think, you know, because I hate him.
Because, like, I think this also, it includes, like, even if he's, like, in the artwork, he's included in a tag.
You know?
True, true, true, true.
So that I won't be surprised if he's just in the corner watching.
Because they're always, like, they always do these type of...
Yeah, yeah.
He's always there.
I feel like, yeah, the great man, he's just be there in the crater.
Don't call him that.
What's his name?
I don't know.
Yeah, cameos count.
Okay, pick my hero.
I'm curious.
Whoa!
93,000!
I'm sorry.
I don't even know who you are.
She's actually very popular Oh good mister i still think erza i think erza yeah yeah like i know like is this site more catered towards like men female you know yeah like girls that are being uploaded i think there would be more yeah i think there'd be more women um on this site too and also like the thing is the more you know how he's like i never watched i only watched the first season of jojo but like you know how like you know he's showing his tummy and stuff like he's just showing it out there but like the more you show the less porn there is of them the less rule 34 because they're like yeah because it's like a psychological thing so like the more like the less there's less to the imagination yeah you know like oh like you know you can't really imagine all of that stuff too so it's like all the more you show the less the less rule 34 art you get because you're like oh you already gave everything to me like what's the point you know the less desire you have i get it i get it yeah
so less is more everybody less is more guys it's like when you show an ankle and they're like oh yeah exactly um i don't know i don't know chainsaw men i didn't watch chainsaw men either yeah let's okay let's the chats oh chat is saying
Look at Hematoh, she's all covered up.
She's all covered up.
You know, less is more.
Yeah, that's just P. Hematoh.
Oh.
Nice.
Oh, not Trish.
Oh, that's hard.
Because she doesn't.
Oh, I still.
Oh, I don't know.
Ah.
I don't.
I don't know.
what do we put like wait actually what do we put classical music as our bgm so we're like yeah what is this song now yeah i know classical music copyright free no i don't
copyright free classical music there you go i know i think we need like fancy like
bach oh bach yeah bach copyright free surely that will be fine no copyright
you're so pure god will forgive us now god will forgive us
um Hmm.
We're so cultured right now.
Oh, madame.
It's actually Duchess Doki right now.
Oh, Dutch.
I am the Duchess of Sealand.
I spent one K to become...
I spent a thousand dollars to become the Duchess of Sealand.
Yeah.
It's the highest form of royalty other than queen.
And not, it's below queen.
Would you like some tea and biscuits, Mint, while we decide who has more Rule 34 posts between Tima No or Trish from Devil May Cry?
No, I would not like your tea and biscuits.
Don't fucking come close to me.
I'm gonna, you know, I feel because I play Devil May Cry, I must bet on Trish.
You want to bet on Trish?
All in?
All in.
Your vices was showing Your vices was showing Oh my, okay, Sakura There's no way I was like, is she like the one the most popular persona?
What the fuck is Monet?
Is she like a filler character?
There's no way this filler character is gonna beat Sakura Yeah, yeah, yeah I was like, who even is she?
Animal Kill!
56,000?!
Sorry, Nanners!
But I think...
I think Animal Crossing has beaten you.
I'm so sorry, Nattasha Nanners.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
But I don't think you will beat 50...
Tori Chica!
Oh, any pineapple sweep anybody, I feel like.
I feel like no matter what's here.
I'm just scared of the number.
I think like Tori Chica is also the most like naked one.
of all the finnaf animatronics i mean look at her shorts i know that look oh wait no freddy's just wearing a bow tie to to be fair he's just letting it all yeah they're all they're all slutting it up up yeah i know right no wonder no wonder um i think chica's gonna be like 20 000 or something know that's 11 000.
oh okay i was out oh that's one's hard that's hard because it's like it's hard because like isn't she one of the more popular ones too in the in the dragon made anime but like always bet on the furries though you know i think always bet on furries always bet on the furries a thousand oh my gosh that's that's it i just read a dogen of her the other day would you like to explain what was the dogen like what was the dogen like what was it yeah she was hiking in the woods oh just hiking in the woods did she meet anybody is she just a little slice of life right a little slice of life a slice of life wow i hope she was safe in the woods i think marney i think marney too i remember like marney had had a lot of people whoa me too oh 5.5 yeah guys don't act surprised I read Dojin like every day she has like every day what did you read today I read Blue Archive
she is appreciating the fine arts guys right She is a...
I just searched Blue Archive and then I read it.
You're like, hmm, what are the new daily uploads for Blue Archive today?
What was it?
What's the tag?
I read one with Slana and...
What were the numbers?
The numbers?
You know, the URL number.
The URL number?
I don't know.
I just look at the name.
What does that mean?
Nuclear launch code.
What were they?
There's a six-digit code, man.
What was six-digit?
I don't know.
There's a code.
What does that mean?
Then you weren't...
Then it wasn't a good dogein.
It's not a good dogein.
There was a second one I read, but I can't even remember what girl it was.
She is a fine appreciator of fine art.
I'm going to look it up.
You're going to look up the fortune.
If you're like fake a gooner, revoke your free card.
If you don't know the numbers.
Hey, what's the numbers?
There's literally nothing here.
Like the date of the morning.
Oh, it was, it was, oh my gosh.
Kisaki.
Is that the title?
no um it's called i can't read i can't read the title everybody i'm so sorry what do people want to want to see it want to just you know check with you to see if it was a good dogen and you want to check your taste it was good here i'll send the name of it in chat but only the japanese one because i'm not i don't
here here's the title chat here you go but You didn't hear it from me.
You didn't hear it from me, okay?
Okay, there you go.
Whoa!
You didn't hear it from me.
Be very quiet.
No leaks.
It's good though.
It's pretty good.
I was saying...
Marnie.
I think Mako is not one of the...
Okay, Fox.
We already know.
Mako?
I think Mako.
Because it's just a also Vocaloid.
I think it's Fox.
I feel like if there's a furry...
Oh, I was looking at the wrong thing.
Okay, you're right.
Okay.
Yeah, I was gonna say, if it's a furry, I think the furry wins.
Yeah, it's Fox.
Yeah, he's been a long-term contender.
Who?
Yeah.
Oh, it's League of Legends.
So, like, only the depressed people would know.
um actually i'm surprised that the toothpaste man has more than i was surprised you 2k i guess i guess there's a also like a bias for newer characters right oh because i was thinking like does he just like a self-insert maybe for the women maybe i think oh girl version there's a girl version of him So they included that,
too.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, is Diana a popular character in League?
Because she's not in Arcane.
It might be a League buff, though.
Like, it might be, you know.
Oh, Mike, I'm not going to read that super chat.
What did it say?
Look at the newest super chat.
Why would you say that?
They need to find joy in their life.
They look at Rule 30.
40.
I would just say that.
Okay.
Do it.
Do League.
Lock in.
League?
I don't even know who she is.
I don't know.
Maybe it is.
Do you know how many characters League has?
Do you know?
No.
It has like 100 plus characters in League alone.
What?
Yeah.
So there's no way.
There's no way.
It's like, you know, the fans are split, you know, into different.
Okay, then do Fire Emblem.
I feel like it'd be Fire Emblem.
there's at least two li clary characters there's 180 li characters yeah i knew i was like oh my gosh
wait oh but that's totally yeah oh no it's toriel it's torio that's torio there's no never bet against the furries yeah yeah kenshin can only uh i still oh this was hard it's like boy love versus hentai i don't know i'm not and it's kona suva isn't that a really popular anime it is it is but she's not the most popular character so she's not oh so it has to be genshin then because he's popular i know he's popular right yeah i feel all the men are popular if i didn't know his number i would say darkness but i but 35 100 is pretty high.
Someone's like, darkness, 100%.
She is to me.
She's like, she's popular to me.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
You're coping right now.
Show me Megumene's numbers right now.
They were wrong.
Oh, but we got 13.
All right, let's get 20 now.
Okay, let's get 20.
She should be the...
Okay, I'm surprised she beat...
Because I thought he was very popular.
Yeah, I thought so.
Oh, no, wait.
But, oh, it's the franchise.
I was going to be like, oh, do you know?
All of the Gundams.
All of the Gundams versus Gene Altair.
I'm just curious, what is the number of the guy?
Like, what is...
In the entire franchise, we have one franchise taker down.
They do know how many.
I know.
Do you know how many Gundams?
Also, which for Mercury would that alone?
will probably know so yeah it's definitely Gundam there's no way oh my god oh it's just for the anime mobile suit Gundam the anime series I thought it was the entire Gundam I thought it was all of Gundam yeah if it was Jake the dog no wait why does Jake the dog look like you though
and just because he's yellow not every yellow character looks like each other why does he look like he looks I am a bird he is a dog you're a cat bird right now you can be a dog bird too
I think it's Jake the dog really Jake the dog how do you I guess because he can shape-shift into anything you want.
It's adventure time.
Oh, yeah.
It is adventure time.
What?
Okay.
I would say...
It's the entire tailspin.
If it was the entire adventure time, I would think it would be adventure time to win.
But...
Well, who's uploading tailspin?
No, D.
Because, like...
Don't the...
What were you...
the the chippendale rescues don't they like overlap with tailspin oh the chippendale yeah yeah and then you know there's a the i think they fly the plane the female yeah they're part of the plane aren't they and then and then there's that female rat in in chippendale rescue rangers uh-huh you know the female rat the female rat you know look you you know what i'm talking about though the female rat in in chippendale wait no i google it google it female female rat chippendale rescue rangers and then look at her she's so cute oh oh gadget yeah yeah gadget okay but i okay i want to say jake the dog but Gadget has a Russian call.
They're very into Gadget.
Oh, wow.
This song is so depressing.
I...
All right, what's your... I think it's tailspin.
I think it's tailspin.
I think it's, like, deep.
I think they're in there.
I knew it.
Sans, Sans, hundred, sans.
Sans, undertail, baby.
Okay, I will... I told my chat this, so you can't be like, Oh my god, because I told I was also a consumer of Sands.
Sands?
Yes!
Wait, with who?
With who?
Like, I don't care.
He was a bicycle.
Sands, reader.
He was like, I don't care who.
It was just, as long as Sands was in there, I'm fine.
Because he was a bicycle.
You know, like, anyone can ride him.
Anyone can.
Hold on.
Bound him.
It has to be.
All right.
The Flintstones?
I think Sands would win.
I don't know.
I mean, we all rule 34.
No.
The Flintstones, I mean, maybe like, what's her name?
Wilma?
maybe.
I mean, there's like sexy Halloween costumes of Wilma.
There is.
Yeah, but is there sexy Halloween costumes of Sans?
Spirit Halloween, write that down.
Spirit Halloween, when will I get my...
When will we get our sexy Halloween costume of Sans Undertale?
Spirit Halloween.
I maybe, I don't know, the Flintstones, it's just, I don't know.
It's one of those things where it's just like you know there's like some like old millennial like yeah 40s who is still going it's still keeping the fandom alive yeah if i go to deviant art right now and search flint stones like what am i gonna get do it okay do it what do you get let me see it should be like oh someone's like what about Barney Barney No,
it's the PL The boy in love between two best friends The OG I'm not kidding any Wait, I think it's because I'm not logged in Hold on Do I have an account?
Mint Phantom This is just Mint Phantom It's because You know the The person that Yeah, I think they did your ending screen.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Whoopion?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I had to commission her on DeviantArt.
So she's like, yeah, because she used to be on DeviantArt before she swapped to Twitter.
I remember.
And I got an email the other day being like, happy birthday.
I was like, oh, but yeah.
So everybody, that's why.
I'm getting, oh, I'm getting, oh.
Whoa, what are you getting right now?
Actually, like, a whole lot of normal stuff.
Who could have thought there were normal people on D-U-D-N-R?
Okay, a whole lot of AI.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I heard, like, D-D-N-R is, like, so rampant with that right now.
That's why we did exclude AI.
We removed the AI results.
All right.
I think it's Sans.
There's no way Flintstones would be.
I think it's like...
Go with Sanson.
Yeah, I was going to say, there's no way.
Yeah.
Who?
Oh, yeah.
It's like, it's life is...
strange but like i've never played that game before this one's hard because i what wait i i i don't i i flintstones i i don't think there's enough rule 34 are you oh my god there is a lot of rule 34 i am back close to why is there so many why is she's the main character why did you guys say that
oh ashley oh ashley ashley oh my god ashley ashley who is she actually i think she's like a sideish character a sideish okay yeah the caesar zeppelzi i think it's it could be mirajane i think maybe It might be here.
Yeah, because, like, there's not a lot of women to pair Caesar with, but it's mostly be a boy love thing.
And I don't know.
I don't know.
Because there's so many Jojos.
You would assume that the Jojos would be the one that compares.
Oh, oh my god, by it.
Barely, barely, barely.
The Caesar sweep.
Not a sweep.
He just crossed the line.
I think fighting game fans are really crazy.
So maybe Tao Kaka.
Tao Kaka?
Maybe.
Oh.
No, it wasn't.
I feel like Rio Zero fans would be crazy.
Oh, boy.
Okay, boyfriend's mostly used as a self-insert, though.
Yeah.
But like...
But it's Sephiroth, though.
Sephiroth, that's less than I thought it would be.
Honestly, true.
I feel like because like people would look at like the other girls more.
I think it's boyfriend.
Is it boyfriend?
Boyfriend, lock in.
Oh, this one's hard.
Oh, this one's really hard.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Oh, this one's hard.
This one's hard.
7K for boyfriend.
I know.
It's just like 7K.
Like how many self-inserts are that you have boyfriend?
But also, like, with Friday Night Funkin, they kind of just put that character in, like, other things.
So it could be, like, it could be, like, Samus, and he's in the background or something.
You know, like, that?
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, you could just be watching, just like the other guy from My Hero Academia.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know here.
I don't know, because, like, the thing.
Oh, because Avatar is such a popular show, too.
It is.
Yeah, and Katara was, like, uh...
Katara's like a main character.
Yeah, she was like...
I mean, she married the avatar.
She literally married the avatar, so...
Oh, that makes her...
That technically makes her main...
Yeah, she was technically the main character by association.
She married.
Wait, did they actually get married?
Get married and have kids.
What do you mean?
Wait, what?
Did you not watch...
Do you not know Legend of Korra?
Oh, that's her...
That's their baby!
No, that's not their baby!
No, that's not their baby.
No, no, no.
She trained the baby.
He had three kids.
So they were...
Oh,
wait.
So, Kora is not their baby.
No, Kora is not their baby.
Do you know how the avatar cycle works?
Do you know how?
Wait.
Wait, no, it doesn't.
When the avatar dies, he gets instantly reincarnated into someone else.
So he's dead?
Yes!
To have...
What do you think?
To have the two avatar?
I'm sorry to break it to you, but...
But Aang died.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry he had the grief now.
Is Katara still alive?
Yes, she's still alive.
She's very old.
Did she kill him so that would be a new avatar?
She died of old age.
What do you mean?
Stop.
It's not his exploit.
To die.
We can't have two avatars.
So eventually, we will have a new avatar.
So he would have had to die.
He would.
Why did you think Katara didn't kill him?
So why would you think Katara would have killed Aang?
Because what if they needed someone with limber?
what because
he has dementia and we're like we gotta get him out we can't have him continue to be he's like we can't have him to continue to be an avatar he's a menace to society we gotta kill him like he's talking about the fire nation i don't know he's like the fire nation still is so evil we gotta get him out well that kind of sucks all three of their kids didn't become the avatar like what are they useless
in order for that to work he has to be like dying during conceivement if he's in the
middle of it then he can restart it's like a bee it's like a bee
I continue the bloodline.
And then they die.
That's true.
They were born, they were born to bang.
That was your purpose.
You're having a heart attack mid-session and to get you reincarnated in your wife's belly.
I've been getting these like short form like like episode series on TikTok recently yeah and one of them they're always it'll always show up in my timeline as like episode 16 or something like that and there's one where I don't know what's going on but the baby has magical powers and like talk to the dad and be like,
father, look, place your hand on mom's belly and I'll transfer the power to you.
What the fuck?
Did he do it?
Yeah, and then it like went to his brain and then they saved the father who had a heart attack.
And maybe...
Why did that save his father from the heart?
Because the baby transferred the magic.
She had spent the magic to stop.
Here, I'll send it to you.
So was he having a heart attack mid-touching the belly or something?
The father had, no, the grandpa had a heart attack, and the baby.
Oh, the baby was like, father, touch mommy's belly real quick, so I can save grandpa.
I'll send it to you right now.
You can even play it on stream.
I'll play the audio of it.
Oh, the audio is good, too.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, well, then you have to see.
Was this in English?
Is the audio in English?
Yeah, it's in English.
It's in English.
Okay, okay.
The visuals are pretty good.
Here you go.
Okay, okay.
Here we go.
All right, guys.
I'll send it to you guys.
You guys can listen to it first before I play it on my screen.
Okay.
Video currently unavailable.
What do you want?
Oh, hold on.
Let me download it.
download it and I'll send it.
It's currently unavailable.
Did they like region locked it to America?
No, I have it.
Aw, broken link.
Wait, but I can see it.
Should I screen or share?
I read a screen share.
It won't let me download it.
Okay, it's not that important.
Let's get back to the game.
It's not that.
It seemed very important.
Wait, wait, wait.
I can play the audio.
Hold on, hold on.
Oh, okay, yeah, yeah.
Are you gonna play the audio on your phone?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'll play it through my mic.
Here we go.
Don't give up.
You gotta hang on.
He's from San Francisco's Green family.
How do I hang on?
Dad, Charles really saved me.
Susan, you're still defending him?
Do you know how bad this is for the family?
Your grandpa already set you up in the Zimmerman family.
And you- Also, these people are all Chinese.
Oh, okay.
Grandpa!
Don't freak me out.
Okay, grandpa.
Hands are short.
My grandpa's in deep trouble.
Someone hexed him.
Is that from the stomach?
Yeah, that's the baby.
Save how?
I hit the doctor.
Susan, sorry.
Dad, catch it.
Catch the magic, dad.
It's not AI, guys.
It's real people.
What the fuck is your TikTok feed?
What algorithms did you?
Did you fake on your TikTok?
It's a bunch of these.
This was episode seven.
I love this ASMR.
Okay.
Through all of that, we have decided that maybe...
I think it's boyfriend.
I think it's boyfriend lock-in.
I'm going to lock in on boyfriend.
Oh.
5K.
Long Kai Star Rail.
Is she a popular?
Is this toy?
Yeah, after 20 minutes of deliberation, we have decided it's a boyfriend.
And after you explaining the whole plot of Avatar.
It's not even the whole plot, it's just explaining to you the Avatar system, the Avatar cycle.
It's just basically no two Avatar.
avatars can be alive it's just that easy anyway is this person popular you guys yeah she popular i don't play gotcha but it's like gotcha but like not this one yeah different gotcha i play different gotcha yeah and she loves consuming dojans of those gotchas of the gotcha yeah i play
Not popular enough.
Katara clears.
Okay, Katara.
Yeah, because apparently she's new.
Oh, she's like new.
Vector the Crocodile.
I think it's Sonic.
I think it's Vector the Crocodile.
There's no...
I mean...
Any Sonic.
Any Sonic character.
I feel like it'd be Vector the Crocodile.
Not 100.
Oh, actually, that's kind of close.
Yeah, that's kind of close.
Oh.
She's not that popular, though, in Demon Slayer, right?
I've never seen her.
I don't know her.
I don't even know where she's...
vector showed up where has she showed up though in demons there i don't know always bet on sonic this girl existed who is she yeah who is she i don't even know she's clearly it played some significance because she has she's like she's like animated you know non-manga she's not just In the manga panel.
Kenjin's wife.
She's one of the three wives.
Yeah, then it's back there.
Yeah.
Is she wife number one, though?
There's no way.
Oh, that's close.
He's there.
I think...
Yeah.
Isn't that main character?
I don't think...
I don't know.
He's so popular, though.
I've seen him everywhere.
Kenjin Impact main character.
20,000.
20.
really yeah she has 20 000.
holy cow melanie oh my god oh that's hard that's hard she's thick yeah exactly she's like thick mommy yeah and pokemon and pokemon that's true oh that's hard like look at those thighs that alone is like 1k one thigh is 1k each people are still saying ether really i guess because it's 20k i mean i would say that yeah i feel like because marine she's popular she only had like what 2k or 3k marney marney yeah marney was like i think marney's more popular than melanie i think so too that's true but like for the oh i mean okay she does that's your that's it this is all up to you this is your this is your niche it was straight through a diva it would be so obvious but like horse robot like so not even the hot kind of robot she's not what are you seeing with your eyes what are you seeing no okay what what's hot about her orissa let me pull up a bigger picture orissa overwatch let's see oh my god what are you what what are you man she's not even the hot Oh The horse legs Yeah The horse legs
Can you share it?
And she's got the horns around Oh my god Okay yeah the better Okay Okay I need to re-okay I need to go re-evaluate What I just said You're The horse No no no no no The horse legs No no no no no The horse legs I'm focusing on that Are you trying to say Horse legs or hot I love centaurs Yes Okay Ha
Yeah?
Yeah.
I feel like we're learning a lot, but I'm in today.
Wow.
More legs equal win.
Everybody knows this.
I think.
Probably.
No.
What?
You're really good.
I really don't see it.
But it is, I would say it is Overwatch.
That's the thing.
But like, the thing is, like, Overwatch, like when Overwatch came out, I remember Pornhub released, like, most popular searches, and, like, Overwatch, at one point, dominated the Oh, yeah, I remember that.
I remember that.
And everyone was like, what the fuck?
And people were like, no, you don't understand.
This was SFM videos.
We're going wild.
but people were like making thousands of dollars each month just making these videos on patreon Melanie is gonna be more because she's more uh appealing to the mainstream I would say so too I think if it was I think it was like if it was tracer or diva I would be like obviously these girls a diva a diva doesn't she probably have like the most out of any Overwatch character I think it's diva or tracer because tracer at one point was like dominating everything until like and then and a diva started slowly gaining more appeal um and a cure cocaine oh mercy mercy too i forgot about mercy yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't want mercy i love that song you could have picked mercy you don't know that song i'm already mercy um pick tracer i'm already tracer
You kidding me, Minimaker?
A thousand, Ferissa.
A lot.
But isn't she the main character of Horizon?
She is, but I don't know if she's that...
I mean, the game is popular.
But is there enough Rule 34?
I think so.
I think it's her.
You think so?
Are you all in?
Will you gamble your life away?
I'm already dead.
That's true.
Oh, nice.
Double or nothing.
Life Weaver.
It's not that popular of a character.
I've never even heard of this person.
He's the newest.
Well, he's not new, but...
But, like, I don't think he's that popular.
Because, like...
He's not new, guys.
He came out, like, one plus two years ago.
He's only...
He came out, like, two years ago.
He's not new.
And have they released anyone since him?
Yes, they've actually recently released a new character last month.
Oh.
And he's like Tumblr's sexy man.
No way.
Wait, what's his name?
His name is.
I think it's like Wu Yang or something.
I think.
Let me look it up.
Yeah, Wu Yang.
He's like...
Oh, you see the Tumblr...
Oh, I see you.
Yeah, yeah, you see it?
I thought he was going to be like, I don't know.
I was expecting the one star yet.
Yeah, I was expecting him in a suit and everything.
No, the thing is, they did a persona collab and they gave him the main character outfit.
Oh, I could see it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you're going to show you.
Oh, man.
Wow, that is Tumblr's sexy man.
Yeah, he looks like the guy from Avatar, no?
Which one?
What?
Saka?
Saka.
Or...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like the same outfit.
Oh, I guess.
Yeah.
I don't know.
What do you mean?
Saka's outfit's not that.
It is like the main...
No, he has bandit.
Oh, you mean all the first... The OG outfit.
Yeah, it's OG.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah, I can sort of see it.
Yeah.
So I was like, Zuko?
Zuko.
I think it's Aloy.
I don't think it's life.
I think he has enough content.
Yeah, definitely not.
I've got 132.
Get off the sign.
What if Nomu has more than life?
I think people use Nomu as a self-insert.
I'm pretty sure.
Because like...
How many people are using Nomu?
No.
No, like you just see the like like just one part of the body and they put no more as a tag No more maybe Yeah, no more.
I feel I feel like it's no more.
There's no My hero the like the name saves him Yeah, the name he's just a name frat.
Oh my god What are we doing with no more?
I did not know your game.
Whoa, what is your game?
No more?
The Nobu is sweet.
Nobu.
I don't know, Trish.
Someone was saying Nobu is like the ugly bastard.
That's what I was thinking.
That's what I was thinking, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You always get like that big ugly creature that's like...
It's like kind of like...
It's kind of like getting like a Minotaur or something.
See, this is why I brought Minotaur.
She's very cultured.
Yeah, he's an orc, right?
He's the orc and the orc massage.
Exactly, it's like getting an orc.
It's like he's getting an orc.
I think Nomu's still.
Nomu's still?
Is it?
Or
say.
Oh, who was it?
Cheese the chow.
No, that's...
No, that's it!
And a cheese!
Ciao!
I can't...
I think because it's Sonic the Hedgehog, then I believe...
Cheese.
Yes, what do you believe about cheese?
I think it's him.
Because it's another kind of character that you can just kind of stick in there, you know?
Like, as like...
Sometimes, I don't know if Rule 34 is like this, but like Donbore is kind of like this.
No, I know they do that.
If a character is like a plushie or something, you know, it'll still tag it.
Oh, no, I agree.
I agree.
So maybe, guys, guys, don't have, don't lose faith in humanity.
He might just be like in the background, guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He might just be in the background.
Oh, you know, I'm glad we're wrong.
I'm so happy.
I'm so...
I'm not.
I wanted to get the 20.
You have no morals anymore You just want You're committed to the grind Oh my god Superior I don't know this character Is he popular?
I don't know him either Or she?
I can't tell I can't tell if you see her she The name is very ambiguous Yeah It sounds like a drink at Starfight I would like one grand day on the Cheeto, please.
Okay, you guys cannot be surprised about 3K for Superior.
I'm honestly surprised it's not more.
It's like Naga.
Yeah.
It's a literal tentacle.
Are you kidding me right now?
But think about this.
The snake.
See, though.
The what?
Thank you.
Snake OC.
Think of...
Oh no, shut up.
Oh, Snake OC!
Alright, lock in, Zerperior.
Just lock in, Zerperior.
Oh!
Oh, I think Genshin Impact.
I don't even know Soraka.
Someone in my chat knows a lot about Snake Anatomy for some fucking reason, and was like, Yeah, Joki, Snake's up too!
how do you why do you know that specific knowledge which one do you choose Soraka why is I mean I don't even know who she is I don't know I think it's also like if it's league they gotta be super popular in league like I feel like I have to know them she's like one of the oldest characters in league so like so like she had the Prime material,
you know?
Oh, that's hard.
The buildup of material.
Then maybe her, yeah.
Yeah, 4.8.
Shante?
Oh, you're an expert.
You're an expert.
Oh, this is how...
I think Shante is very popular, but beating...
This song.
But does it beat league popular?
I don't... I think Shante is like...
She's like a sex symbol.
She's...
She's super hot.
I think Shantae.
Oh, you got it.
It's Shantae.
That's my girl.
Are you gonna stick with your girl?
Shantae.
Yeah, I think Shantae.
Oh, yeah.
Ermi's had nothing.
Ermi's Conan.
Oh, I hate when it's a battle between unpunk.
Yeah, yeah.
It's like the way the fuck is.
It's just...
Yeah.
Who?
There's so many Naruto characters.
man.
There is so many.
Yeah, I don't I mean, it's under Naruto.
Naruto is more popular than Jojo, right?
I guess technically.
And like, like, I don't know.
I feel like with more Naruto degenerates than Jojo, I feel like Conan would win, right?
Like, oh, apparently she's the one, she's the only girl.
Is she the only girl?
There's no way she's the only girl.
She's the only What is it called?
A cat?
What is it called?
I don't know, I've never watched her.
Have you watched Naruto?
I've never watched Naruto.
No, I've never.
She is the only evil, evil girl.
Oh, she's the only girl.
Okay, she's the only girl, so like they have nothing to like steal.
Screw you, Kimata.
Oh, okay, yeah, there we go.
Alright.
Tangles the Lever.
Okay, even though I would say the Sonic buff, who the fuck is Tangles the Lever?
And it says, like, yeah.
But, I don't know.
Like, who's Tangled?
Like, this person existed?
Oh, only in the comics, too.
It says, yeah, Sonic the Hedgehog comp.
But there's, like, a, there's, like, a CG of her, so.
Maybe it's fan-made.
Maybe she has a model.
I don't know.
Sonic fans would do anything for, like, any Sonic character.
But, like, she's only- But enough to beat 2,665?
The five?
Is it, is Sonic enough to be?
be conan the only girl in the in the gang what if what if tangle has 2666 it's sonic but it's like hard because it's like not yeah because like how many sonic fans read the comics how many wait we got uh we got that one guy from sonic earlier yeah he was 900 900 so i feel like tangle was be Yeah,
I think it's Conan.
Oh my god, 2,100 for Ruben.
Who is he in here?
What?
Why is the streamer in here?
Who is the- What?
Okay, zero post.
Okay, I'm so- Then he can't be on this site!
Why is he in the site?
Who is he?
How did they put- Wait, how do we add ourselves in here?
Oh wait, no, we are in here.
Wait, can we make suggestions?
suggestions in here?
How do we make ad-p-things?
Also, whoever uploads here does not upload enough VTuber stuff.
Like, Watame only having 392?
That ain't right.
I don't believe that.
Look up Damboree right now.
How much is you?
Look, okay.
If I do Damboree and then also like...
Wait, hold on.
I say Damboree.
Let's see.
What's...
Uh...
Su-no...
Well, actually, I feel like Pixiv would be a better gauge.
Oh, apparently there's like vile clips of Ruben.
That's why he got in.
So I think the developers added him as an Easter egg.
That's why.
He breaks the R34 rules.
Yeah, he breaks... Because there's zero posts of him.
That means it doesn't follow.
It doesn't.
Oh, I guess it's like the free card in Bingo.
Oh, yeah.
All right.
How many in Damboro?
uh people are saying 3.1k but i don't know if that includes the safer work and not safe if they i don't know but 3.1 3.1 that's pretty good yeah i think that's just the safer work there's no way there's no no that doesn't include the safer work they mix they mix like the not safe and safe for work stuff so you gotta like you gotta put like rating safe or whatever oh i see i was like there's no way it's that low i was like there's no way all right Who's Siri?
I think she's like one of the main characters, no?
Is she?
I've never played the witch.
Yeah, we're so classy right now.
We're making some classy decisions in life.
Oh, so I was like, Witcher has 11k on Pixiv alone.
Oh, this feels like we're doing some, we're making some holy decisions right now.
In the name of God, we are picking, we are picking.
Siri!
Siri?
Yeah.
Oh my god, 11k?
Tails.
Oh, Tails.
There's no way.
Tails clears off.
Tails, thank you.
No!
I still think it's Tails.
It has to be Tails.
I don't think the entire franchise of winning the...
But thank god.
Thank god.
Inside of the Korra.
Because like, why do they had so little though?
Why is she have no picture?
the only picture they could find was not safe for work i think poo having 1300 almost 1400 is really horrible it's pretty bad oh my god i guess it's the mom it's it's kanga's mom i guess like okay okay you had okay you had 2k yeah her mom has a lot and but a lot of the other girls haven't a bunch so it really depends on who's uploading them you know you have that one okayu fan that's exactly you have some dedicated okayu fans but check what out does she have a dedicated fan yeah does she have a dedicated oh my god that means there's a dedicated witty the poo enthusiast that's been uploaded when do you think the most recent witty the poo was uploaded i'm not searching i'm not putting that in my search history that is not going in there you you can the honor man you can oh i'm not doing that yes three hours ago three hours ago was the last winnie the poo upload no way
i want to say it has to be pakora but like do we have a dedicated pakora fan that is updating rule 34 let's try see oh my god don't worry i'm playing this game in incognito mode so do i think try pekora pekora oh thank god thank god oh marie oh this one's hard this is hard marie i think marie it should be marie because like her music videos and everything yeah yeah in the battle of the titans i think it's marie and she's like she's a hag too is you know so the hag buff yeah hag buff there's no way it's not her oh thank god thank god thank you to the to the one enthusiast marine fan that's uploading on rule 34
I don't know fire I think she's a main character though is she a main character I don't know I don't play fire I thought so the age of 30 using the man 18 for the 10th year is she has she been 18 for the yeah yeah 30 guys 30 yeah yeah and then when you're 40 you're practically just dead right violet has a mate has a dude version too so i think it's oh it should be violet because there's yeah probably yeah oh yeah there it is there you go with the combination of yeah the entire hollow life there's can the entire franchise of Hololive beat one Fire Emblem character.
Okay, we add them up.
Okay, Oka, you had 2K.
But Korra had 1K.
So that's already, you know, that's already 3K.
And then we add Marine.
That's 8K.
Now we have the rest of the...
There's no way.
Wait, is this including, like, English?
Yeah, this is.
There's an entire...
It's definitely Hololive.
It has to be Hololive.
There's no way.
I'm like adding up the ones that we saw.
Oh my god.
66.
I'm sorry, Sayori.
You're not beating 66,000 dollars.
Guda is like half of the house.
Yeah, I was going to say Guda is going to be like 30k.
I would say Sayori.
Juvie's not a main character, right?
Uh, Juvia is...
It's like, Sayori is huge in Western Adams.
I think probably it's Sayori.
Yeah, it should be Sayori.
She would be in all the group pictures.
I think Juvia is a bigger character, but I don't remember.
I didn't watch Fairy Tale, my roommate did.
I didn't watch it either.
Juvia, hands down, Sayori.
Someone's like, Juvia is very popular.
To be is still gunable.
What made it stop being gunable?
I don't know.
I think Kodokie Doki is such a big, like...
Yeah.
I mean, so is Fairy Tale, but...
That's true.
Fairy Tale's been around for a while.
Yeah.
I don't know here.
We could... Wait, what's our streak right now?
It's 16.
It's the best we've done so far.
You guys, this is important!
This is important!
Lock in, lock in!
We got locked in.
We got hit 20.
I would say Sayori is bigger in the West.
I think Sayori.
I'm going to say Yori.
Oh, that was bad.
Everybody who said Juvia, easy.
Juvia, there's no way Baptiste.
There's no way.
I'll trust you.
Yeah, that's reasonable.
Chihaya.
Mifune Chihaya from Persona 5.
I mean, she's a girl, so I assume she'll have more just because of that is she she i've never seen her before though i feel like i feel i've never seen her either but like just because she's more than 210 yeah more than 200 200 is so and that removes oh It's a song!
It was
such perfect timing!
Our streak!
Oh, Jill Valentine.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, this one's hard.
It has to be Morgan!
She was like the gooner girl for longest time uh but then jill shows up so many times though i don't know honestly how you go oh my god i don't know i okay jill we'll go in then jill oh 18k okay good good good yeah yeah i was gonna say who the oh morgan morgan morgan yeah i was gonna say there's no way why does she have 2800!
Oh, wait.
Yay!
We got a freebie!
The game felt sorry for us.
Yay!
Here we go from Fate.
From Fate Geo.
I think it's still Morgan.
There's no way.
Freebie, baby!
Freebie!
The game felt bad for us.
Pearl!
Oh, I think it's Pearl.
I think it's Pearl.
Splatoon is huge.
Yeah, it's huge in, like, Japan, too.
It has to be Pearl.
yeah if it was the other one then it'll be even more shadow heart shadow heart right shadow heart oh my god bye oh my god it's our freebie race these are baldergate fans what are you doing what are you doing what happened balder's game won game of the year for nothing how dare you not start gooning i think i know i would pick a little versus you you It's a Yu-Gi-Oh-Hakusho.
Yu-Gi-Oh-Gi-Oh-Gi-Oh-Shou.
But it's Piccolo.
I'm surprised Piccolo only has 600.
Oh, I'm gonna tell him.
I feel like...
No, I think it's because then...
Is it only Dragon Ball Piccolo or does it include Dragon Ball Z Piccolo?
Oh, that's true.
Because it says anime and manga.
So it could just be like...
Because it doesn't need Dragon Ball Z.
Or anything.
Yeah.
I don't know.
But it's like the character...
That's true.
Yeah, I can't tell.
All right, just barely.
You almost...
Storm, the Albatross.
There's no way.
Always bet on Sonic, right?
Why?
We haven't before in the past, but try, try, try.
I'm curious.
Oh.
I was like, I don't remember.
Oh, Hasman Hotel.
Hasman Hotel?
The entire... Oh.
Oh, Isol.
Isol.
For sure.
At little?
I would think... At little.
At a pretty hot dog!
Are the furries that damn bad?
Animaniacs.
The nurse.
Hello, nurse.
I think it's Animaniacs.
It has to be.
The nurse.
The nurse carries.
I don't know what nurse you're talking about, but I believe you.
You don't know the famous line.
Hello, nurse.
Hold on.
Anime.
Let's see how hot she is.
Animaniacs.
I don't know what she looks like, but I know.
Nurse.
Yeah, it's a nurse carry.
I told
her.
I'm literally a wugaiing right now.
She carries!
I told you!
Damn, guys, she's hot!
Wait, I'm sending it to you?
Yeah?
Oh!
She's so sexy!
Yeah, hello!
Nerds!
Oh, nerds!
I'm sick.
I'm so sick right now.
I can't, I don't know.
No skates.
a popular character he is he is one of the main characters and it's demon slayer so oh my god not popular enough apparently there's no way oh yeah there's no way uh i'll see it look like a toho is that toho it's definitely ochako it's definitely 16k running these i remember hemeno right yeah hemeno yeah i don't remember exactly the number but I remember she had like four digits.
Yeah.
Bowser.
It's Bowser.
Bowser sweep.
One of my friends was a Bowser enthusiast.
Like, like, and they would draw Bara Bowser.
All right.
Wait, do you want me to show you one?
Yeah.
Wait, yeah.
Wait, you have it?
Just on there?
No, I was like, okay, yesterday I was doing a member stream and I was looking through my storage.
And because I had like uploads and stuff.
that i stored um of old art that i saved of my friend's art and my art and and one of them was a powser art that my friend drew made into a pin okay let's show wait yeah show me oh my friend sent me it's not as it's oh wait what's the what's the bottom half
an explicit i don't remember i don't remember i just remember i'll show it to chat this was an art a button that my friend made and sent
so it has to be bowser it's bowser for sure there's no way it's bowser for sure we just got the mario movie like there's a bowser market out there and a very i think he's in the 10 000 oh my 16 oh freebie let's go freebie yay the king has to be whitney right i but there's so many animal crossing i know there's so many animal there's so many there's always a favorite though maybe it was isabel i would say animal crossing oh yeah isabel would be but what didn't we get animal crossing earlier and it was like crazy like 10 000 something i don't remember exactly the number i think it's whitney it has to be whitney right oh my god there's too many every time we get a freebie man oh my god this is hard because they're popular i don't know i don't know i want to say marina but i know she's popular too our furry our furry logic is losing us no has marina how can thank god i know marina is like super popular too no well holiday Noel,
oh, I think it's still this Ito guy.
Is it Ito?
But then, like, remember the driving meme in Undertale?
Isn't she part of it?
I don't know the driving meme.
Oh, you don't know that.
Actually, I don't know anything about Delta Rune, so I don't know.
I'll leave it up to you.
Wait, people are saying Noel Sweep.
What?
Noel cleared.
Yeah, driving in my car.
Have you not heard about driving in my car?
No.
Where, like, the guy runs over, runs over people.
No, I've never heard of this.
Oh.
It's Noel.
Oh my gosh!
One Piece.
The entirety of One Piece.
I don't even need to know.
Oh, One Piece.
Yeah.
I was like, I don't even need to know what's...
Oh, High School D...
Oh, she's one of the main characters, no?
I don't know.
I never watched this.
You're my anime expert.
You're my...
You're the call of my friend.
I didn't watch High School DXD!
I think it's that one.
I think it's High School DXD.
It's High School.
Yeah, see?
Oh, beating the entire Anahara, Hana, Well, I don't know.
It's sparkle.
This guy never hit a thousand.
Yeah, Sparkle.
Eventually.
This is hard.
Because like, Clone Wars.
She's, yeah, she's a main character.
Yeah, isn't she?
Yeah, okay.
I remember.
I never watched Clone Wars, but I remember she was popular in Clone Wars.
Bleach.
I think, she's also popular, but I still think it's Ahsoka.
Ahsoka?
Yep.
Wow, yeah.
We're blazing through this.
We're gonna hit 20, guys.
Yeah, we're gonna hit 20.
We're gonna hit 20.
What the fuck is Twin Rova?
Stream ends at 20?
Yeah, stream ends at 20.
I don't know.
I don't know, Twin Rova.
I don't know either.
I was gonna say, this person is...
Yeah, it looks like a boss.
Oh, holy!
No, you don't understand.
Kiriko, fucking clears.
This is hard.
I still think it would be Kiriko.
I don't think it would be Kiriko just from the end.
SFM videos alone.
There's a lot.
I mean, Vincent, obviously, but like, yeah, Kiriko, I think it's Kiriko.
It's Kiriko.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Vincent was just crawling on the ground.
Oh, Chica.
Chica.
Wait, why do we get, why do we have, wait, why are there two Chicas?
You don't know Toy Chica?
Toy Chica was from Spinab too.
No, no.
Before it was Toy Chica.
Yeah, this was Chica.
Oh, okay, okay.
Chica was the OG Chica.
And then like, She went on and then Chica got on to Ozempic and then she became Toy Chica.
Yeah, that's what happened.
That's what happened.
So I forgot.
I thought it was just Chica before.
I didn't, I forgot it was Toy Chica.
My bad, everybody.
Chica sweet.
Chica time.
5k.
Jesus.
Has to be Full Metal Alchemist just alone.
Just from the boy love in general.
Full Metal Alchemist catered a lot to the BL fandom.
It did.
There were some hot girls in it too.
Yeah, that's true.
Alright, who was your favorite ships in Full Metal Alchemist?
Were you a Full Metal Alchemist fan though?
Yeah, but I didn't ship anybody.
Oh, I did.
Oh.
I shipped a couple.
You're a real Fujo.
I shipped a couple before I read Full Metal Alchemist.
Wait, who?
Who?
Roy and Hughes.
I think a lot of people.
Yeah, a lot of people ship them though.
Okay, so...
Sometimes what I do is if I like the couple, I just like, I just read, I don't know what the actual source material is.
I just like how they look good together.
And then I just read fan, I don't know.
And then I learn the source material through fan fiction.
And from piecing together the context clues.
So like, how did Roy and Hughes work?
Because Hughes is, like, he's famous for being like, this is my darling daughter.
She's so cute.
During the training days, the military before.
they met and then it's like and then you know that's why roy is like extra emo because he chose his wife right that's good see that's good you get it you get it yes oh
my gosh and there's just this sexual tension that they always have best friends you know best friends to lovers oh you understand you understand now i'm an ex-fujo by the way i don't do that no Ex-Fujo, ex-Fujo, I don't do that anymore.
I only, I only Fujo one series, basically.
Because, like, my Fujo sense is retangling when my friends keep telling me to watch Arcane.
Have you ever watched Arcane?
No.
I haven't either.
But, like, I remember they showed me some characters, and there were two characters.
And I was like, oh, are they a thing?
I saw it.
That was gay bark.
Yeah, I saw two characters.
I was like, oh my god, are they a thing?
Oh, this is interesting.
I don't know anything about the show.
And I was just...
You guys, it's not EX as in X, EX.
It's X as in the letter X.
She's still a food show.
And then they're like...
And then one of my friends was like, no, one of them is dating this other girl.
And I was like...
I was like...
Ex-a-doubt, yeah.
I hate it.
Okay, it has to be full metal alchemist.
I definitely have hated girl characters because they messed with my shit.
Yeah, yeah.
That was me with Axel and Roxas and the girl thing.
They introduced, why did they need to- Why did they have to introduce the random nobody who doesn't even have a fucking soul?
I know that argument.
I didn't ship them, but my friend was a hardcore Roku.
What was it called?
Akuroku.
Yeah.
My women friends was a hardcore Akuroku.
And like, they were, they were so mad.
I would hear their rants about Zion.
What was it?
What's it?
Zion?
Zion or Zion or something?
Honestly, I kind of fell out of the games.
Not because they introduced her, but like, I'd stop.
Like, Kingdom Hearts lore got too crazy for me.
Oh yeah, it's true.
I didn't play them.
Even the director would, you know how the, like, director or the writer of the Kingdom Hearts games would watch recap videos to remember what he wrote.
No way.
He watches YouTube recaps because he lost track of the plot.
So he's like, okay.
It shows.
Isn't it no more?
Oh my god.
Anyway, full metal alchemist.
Full metal alchemist.
Why?
Why would we doubt FNAF fans, honestly?
Why would we doubt FNAF?
Oh my god, we can never get past 10 anymore.
I know.
It's so derpy.
Oh no.
No.
It has to be derpy.
No, the bronies.
I think it's derpy.
The bronies.
The bronies overpower FNAF.
There is no way.
Yeah.
I think it's, yeah.
There's, oh thank god.
Okay, it's close.
It's, oh.
Oh my god.
Oh, she's not.
Okay.
Yes, she is.
But she came.
She came in on the last two seasons and Derpy has been here since OG times and she be and she got promoted to be a mailman Yeah, yeah, yeah There's no Derpy there it has to be derpy.
There's no way What I told you I told you I told you I thought because everyone's lucky.
Oh my high school.
No.
Oh my god high school the dead though No, it's still Sylvia.
That's true.
It's Sylvia on high school dead shows too much yeah exactly my life as a teenager okay but she was like my crush of crushes it's jenny but she's her franchise too i mean jenny alone jenny alone i don't know i love jenny and she's she's a hot robot too if this site caters more Tour Western,
then it would be It would be Jenny, right?
What if someone was just uploading manga panels?
Oh, I don't know.
What is it?
I want to trust in the robot freaks.
Okay, all right.
We trust.
Oh, thank God.
I'm so...
Thank God.
Oh.
I would...
Azuna.
I mean, Katara got 2K, right?
Katara got 2K.
so was it 2k yeah azula's hot though look at her true azula is oh my god why we fucked up our freebies we fucked up our freebies they were having someone said katara was 7k oh 7k so it has to be wait but katara is more popular in azula i don't know about that azula is the main like she's the main baddie she's the main baddie She's the main batty,
baby.
I think it's Azula.
The avatar is way more popular than my life as a teenage robot.
That's true.
I can't believe you doubted.
I can't believe you doubted your childhood crush.
I can't believe you doubted her.
She was...
I can't believe I doubted her.
She was there for you.
She was there for you, and you weren't.
You were not there for her when she needed you the most.
I can't believe it.
I'm throwing.
I have to be Dobby, right?
I think it's Dobby.
He's the bad boy.
You would be like, Oh my god.
I can't believe Doki.
I can't believe it.
What do you mean you can't believe?
Oh my god.
It's Pearl.
It's Pearl, right?
Yeah, it's Pearl.
We should know.
No, it was Sans.
Sans was like, wait.
No.
He's Sans.
Where's my Sans?
Someone upload four more right now.
Someone upload.
Upload four more sands undertale on rule 34 right now.
I need four people to upload Just draw something at MSP.
Yeah, just draw something and upload it right now.
I refuse to please sands and lose Sands should never lose unless it's against like a franchise Has to be umbrian Yeah, this is from smash bros alone, I feel like Yeah.
500.
That's not a lot.
It's not a lot.
Oh, Sombra's.
Yeah, SFM.
I was going to say she's popular.
She's a Latino representation.
Aether had like a lot.
Yeah.
How it was like 10K, wasn't it?
Was it 10K?
It was a lot.
I think it was like 10K.
I remember it.
Yeah, yeah.
It was.
It was him.
Yeah, pick him.
Pick him.
Oh, thank God.
It was 20K.
That was a lot more than 10K.
Oh, more.
I'm sorry.
Sorry, Callie.
I'm sorry, Callie.
But I don't.
you're feeding Genshin today.
I don't want to I don't want to think about Callie.
It has to be Makima.
Even I know who she is and oh no no I'm so I mean I talked to this person.
It's like hey I think I saw a real 34 interview today.
No just pick Makima please.
fuck do you mean you saw you literally searched up world 34 i don't be right on during this stream that's you what does that mean
oh i mean sam is alone sam is oh yeah it's metroid right yeah sam is alone she was like og gooner bait she wears a skin suit like a tight suit like but like but also machi Hima is, like, recent, so it's hard.
Oh, I think it's Samus, though.
It has to be Samus.
Samus is so popular in Western culture.
Oh, thank God.
26K.
I went with my gut.
Okay, okay.
All right, it has to be, I don't know who the fuck Pura is, but it has to be.
I don't think it's 26K, Pura.
35, yeah.
Oh, I don't know about that one.
Viper is popular.
She came on launch.
she like she's like a bad bitch too she yeah she's a bad bitch i know i i saw a lot of perro when like that game came out but i i think i guess try viper i don't know i don't know a valorant enough uh she's a popular character in valorant too but is she popular enough to be a gooner character she's probably i know valor's popular in japan are they gooning to her in japan i know this simsita is not japan though that's true but valor is popular in na people saying that she's not that popular i think go with legend of zelda i don't know okay i'm scared i'm scared oh thank god okay all right we went with the gun no game no life there's no way it's not i think it's yeah there has to be okay what Where are the weebs at?
Where are the weebs at?
Where is my...
Someone upload a thousand pictures right now.
But not AI.
Not AI.
No way.
Someone migrated Dambaru's images into Rule 3 anymore.
There's no way!
But it's so popular.
Even I know no game, no life.
Even I know.
It's so popular.
That's crazy.
Wait, Shadowheart was not at, like, super popular.
popular well she was but like not as popular as we expected yeah i remember it wasn't which is insane because like i feel like she is the character yeah from balder's gate i think it was it was lower right i think so go with v v oh my god it was 4k it's fine mu2
6k?
What are we doing?
Link.
Oh, thank God.
The game.
Oh.
I still think it's Link.
Is it still Link?
Okay.
Yeah.
Because I know her, too.
Yeah, she's...
I don't know her.
There's...
She has to be new.
I don't recognize her at all.
Rin.
Yeah, Tosaka Rin.
Tosaka Rin?
Yeah.
Because I never seen her before.
I never even seen trailers of her.
Enderman!
It's a fine Tumblr sexy man.
Have you seen like the Minecraft?
There's like a Minecraft like a special Minecraft community dedicated to...
What are we saying here?
What are we saying here, Doki?
Dedicated to maybe Rule 34 stuff of Minecraft characters.
Wow.
It was a very especially...
Did you know about the Minecraft mod?
Oh, I've heard about those.
I've heard about those.
Oh, you know, you heard about the Minecraft mod that got C synthesis from Minecraft itself.
Wait, I don't know that.
What?
There's a mod.
There's an infamous Minecraft mod.
Where it's...
It's called...
It's called Jenny.
I'm looking it up.
It's called Do Not Download Anything, by the way.
Do Not Download.
I would just tell, do not download anything related to the...
Oh, jenniesmod.com?
Don't go to the website.
Because the real website, the real website...
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
It's her bag!
Do not download anything.
Because the real creator of the thing got a cease and desist.
So the only way to obtain it is through very not legal means.
And there are other websites that would upload viruses with the Genie mod because they know that Gooners are desperate.
Because the main, the only way to obtain it is to find the developer's Twitter.
And he would occasionally apparently, because I was reading up about it, because I was curious.
about this Jenny mod and people were saying yeah sometimes the developer will tweet out about ways to get it but he would delete it really fast so because he hasn't he can't update it at all because he got these sentences from Minecraft and stop oh because it's sexy like yeah because it's it's not just sexy admit it's more than
Someone put a video Jenny mod in VR
It's a little It's a little more than just So what virus did you get when you downloaded it?
So Okay, okay, okay Funny story But I was talking to one of my friends about the Minecraft mod Jenny And then I was like Oh, you should download it And then I accidentally And then I was Are you saying you accidentally don't lie No I actually gave Made the person get spyware Because Because I was like Click that link Because there's free sharing Like which link do I click?
I was like click that one And then they got spyware And then I got So
I felt so bad I felt so fucking bad Like I Don't download it.
Just download McAfee.
Kind of
disappointed she doesn't look more like Laura Croft.
Don't worry there are other characters apparently.
There's other characters.
There are.
There's a slime girl.
There's a slime.
Don't download the mod.
I don't want you to get- You guys, I do not endorse.
I don't want anyone to get spyware.
I don't- I don't- I thought there's...
Don't download a mod called Jenny Minecraft.
Do not redeem.
Do you think it's Enderman?
It's happening again.
Do not redeem.
Okay.
Oh, it's hard to tell.
It's hard to tell because he could be a self-insert too.
I want to trust in my Minecraft crush.
Your Minecraft crush?
Your Tumblr sexy man?
You're going all in.
Yeah, my Tumblr sexy man.
Oh, the 2.9 Iron Mouse.
I'm sorry, Iron Mouse.
You're not sexy enough, apparently.
You're not.
What?
These are Tumblr sexy men.
It has to be a Sukuna, right?
Oh, it's Sukuna.
Yeah, I think it's Jyotokai.
Yeah, it's Jyotokai.
Yeah, I think it's still Sukuna.
Is it still Sukuna?
Yeah.
Guys, we're about to break 10.
It's been so long.
Wait, but this is like two side characters.
Oh, that's true.
But she's in My Hero Academia, so she shouldn't.
Wait, what is she?
Oh, she's not a Cyclone girl, right?
I have no idea if she is.
Why is it?
Because, like, the cyclone.
Yeah, isn't she like the girl that's...
The one that had like, that can create like little cyclones, but like...
I think it's my hero.
Yeah.
Because like, why does she have short hair now?
I don't know.
Spoilers?
Oh, spoiler.
Yeah, because I was like... Yeah, she's like one of the big... Like, she has like...
She's part of the, like, the Senpai squad.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I remember her long.
Yeah.
Yeah, I just think... Okay, this is your forte.
Oh, my God.
It's hard.
Ash is pretty popular.
that about Valorant girl too.
Because Viper is!
Wait, but Viper, didn't Viper win?
Was supposed to win that we didn't pick her?
No, Viper didn't win.
Oh, Viper didn't win.
I forgot already.
That's how little I care about Valorant.
I think it's Ash, just from the SFM videos.
I knew it.
Ash.
Oh, the way.
Oh, Palutino.
But Kid Icarus is like, they don't care.
Like they don't care about They don't care Like they never make Kid Icarus games though Yeah I feel like it'd be ash I think it's still ash Yeah Oh Did you care Did you care Will we ever get to 20?
Every time we're just like It's a western sight We go with a western character It's the opposite Like this Like scout Scout Yeah I was on Guys, I was on The What was it called?
There was like a special forum For Team Fortress 2 I was on that site Wait, there was a What is it?
It's like a special anonymous Forum for Team Fortress 2 And I was on that site I browsed that site religiously With fan fiction and art Oh wow I don't remember what it was called I It was a special anonymous site for it.
I don't remember what it was called.
It was just all for Team Fortress 2.
It was just...
Was it Yowie?
No, no, there was other stuff.
I mean, they have a section for it, but there were other stuff too.
Oh my god.
uh wait we did we got morgana morgana before right but this is league of legends yeah but we got her before and i was like i think it was scout because she wasn't that much okay pick scout yeah i remember i remember i don't remember her at all has to be him right haiku is so popular this is league of legends that's true but the women upload stuff on i don't know i don't i I think her still.
I don't know.
Oh, no.
They're on Dambodu.
That has to be her.
Yeah, it has to be her.
Oh, Chun-Li.
Chun-Li.
Wait, I'll be right back.
You pick one.
Oh.
Oh, this is so high.
It has to be Chun-Li, right?
Oh, my God.
It absolutely is Chun-Li.
It absolutely...
It should be Chun-Li again.
I know Colin and Cat wasn't that much, guys.
Okay, guys, thank freebies.
We gotta do it.
We're gonna get past Tom's shit.
The hardest decision requires the greatest war, the strongest warriors.
We need meant to be here.
Green versus green.
The man himself.
Shrek is love.
Shrek is like It has to come back here For the hardest decision of our life
The CEO Of green I don't know Like I feel like it should be Shrek Right?
Just with like as a Cameo
We're having a very intense debate right now Midlife Who won the other one?
Oh, it was Chun-Li.
Chun-Li, Chun-Li, Chun-Li.
Yeah.
It's gotta be Shrek.
Yeah?
I think so.
He's the main character.
That's true.
But, like, how many posts would he have?
2K.
Where are my Shrek fans?
What?
Don't get me.
Shrek fans!
I'm plotting my way for the Shrek now.
What?
There's no way.
I can't.
believe it you would think shrek who the fuck is carrot i don't know she's a bunny girl she's a bunny girl just because oh my god she's a very important bunny girl oh my god sarja sarja she's so important apparently yeah oh yeah fate the franchise yeah uh still fate still fate yes i'm 801 75 745 she holds the entire Resident Evil franchise this is hard I think it's Konosuba though I feel like it like it's popular yeah there's a bunch of popular characters yeah thank god that's kind of close though oh but it's still Konosuba yeah I was gonna say I don't think there's enough enough up oh my god but it's Gojo okay thank god there's not enough um masu I I think it's oh this is This is hard.
Masuo is like a...
She's a very popular character.
Is that...
I think it's her.
But is she more special than Glojo?
I think it's Masuo.
But he is special.
Special.
Oh, yeah.
He's not special.
Oh, Catra.
Oh, that's hard.
I don't know.
I don't...
I don't think Catra has a big enough fandom, though.
That's the thing.
I don't know, Shira.
I watched this series.
It was pretty decent.
but like i don't know if she i think it's machu still she's pretty yeah yeah i was gonna say i don't think she is popular enough fate has like oh matumura rangiku
she have big character i think i've seen her before but i don't oh people are saying rangu rangiku rangiku oh oh is it just because she's a mom
No way!
What
do you mean?
Tails alone was...
It's Knuckles.
Come on.
Look at his fist.
They're shaped like nipples.
It's not...
Look at Knuckles' fist!
It's really nipple shaped!
Oh, have you seen the nipple comic from Knuckles?
No, I don't know what you're talking about.
Okay, don't worry.
Don't worry.
All right, let me show you.
This...
Okay.
After reading this comic, I'll give you a little fun fact.
Oh, God.
Does he chuckle?
I'll give you a little fun fact about this comic.
But basically...
After...
The artists...
Who...
The artists who did this comic...
End up officially illustrating Sonic art.
For...
Oh!
For Sega.
No, it was before...
Before he became...
He became... So it's canon.
Technically it's canon.
I wouldn't say that.
He's an official Sonic artist.
Dreams do come true!
Dreams do come true.
Come true.
Oh.
Oh, I don't.
I don't know.
Okay, delete it.
Wait, I remember the guy was going to report this message.
Delete it.
What do you mean?
You're going to report my message?
I'm going to say this entire franchise, Miku.
Because I would have had to name Miku.
He was like 21k.
Miku.
Oh, oh, oh, sorry, Polnarov.
Oh, uh, Sakura.
Yeah, I've seen her before.
Yeah, she's very popular.
Yeah.
Oh, kill, kill.
It's seen in the franchise.
Yeah, I think it's kill, the kill.
Yeah.
You're all, like, naked, almost naked.
Oh, wait, who the fuck is she?
It's Bam Bambieta Basturbine.
Basturbine.
Yeah, that seems right.
I was like, who ish?
Who is?
Jump scare Okay, I'll quickly close it down Oh
shit, I forgot I think it's Kegel I think it's Kegel have i don't remember but he said run that we're like next next next get get that thing away as far as possible get that away he had like 800 okay okay 800 oh my god oh world of warcraft come on just from the ocs alone this is like this is my world of warcraft oc holy shit i think that's the closest we've That's what?
To like 100,000.
Oh my god.
There's a lot of World of Warcraft OC's.
Yeah, the elves alone kind of like.
Yeah, the night elves.
Holy cow.
Okay.
I guess you'll beat Inosuke.
For Inosuke.
Oh, Higurashi.
Wait.
Didn't they say like, oh wait.
I still think Higurashi.
There's a lot of characters in this.
That's true.
Yeah, all the characters combined only is half of...
That's... Oh, it has to be Rey.
Right!
It's gotta be Rey.
Yeah, she was OG Guder.
Yeah.
She's like the OG waifu.
There's no way.
It's a good show that they cancelled after the first season because I think it was an inside job.
I think they got too close to the truth and then the government cancelled them.
It was such a good show.
But it was basically like talking about the Illuminati and everything.
to the truth no i thought my guy would beat inside job how many we were so close
so no they didn't have a second season they divide the first season in half and then said it's the second season so the entire two seasons was from the first season there's no way it's courage right i'd be very i don't think so but yeah i was gonna say It's our first thing,
it's fine.
DuckTales.
Ooh.
Tiny Toons Adventure or DuckTales?
I think it's Tiny Toon.
Because there's more characters.
Okay, you're right.
Because I was like thinking there's more Looney characters.
Murder drones.
I mean, it's from the same franchise that did.
What is Murder Drones?
Well, it's from Glitch Productions who did the...
Oh, like a digital circus.
Yeah, digital circus.
They did digital circus, but I don't know if they're that popular.
I don't think...
If it were digital circus, I think.
But Tiny Toons, I think, is still winning here.
Oh, I guess we're wrong.
I guess it has to be Hasbun Hotel.
You could just be there as a side character.
I don't know these guys.
I think it's the JoJo's.
Is it?
Oh, just...
It's Dragon Ball.
Kefla?
She was pretty popular in the newer ones.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, and, oh, it's from all of Dragon Ball because she was in the newer Dragon Ball series.
So she should be.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Kiriko, I remember.
No.
We've fucked up so much.
Wait, versus Sanji?
Sanji?
Okay, but SFM.
I think it's still Kiriko.
I think, like, Sanji not as popular.
Brawl stars Bro, it's a mobile game Are people trying Or in a mobile game still I mean Yeah
Should be Sanji right Yes Oh my god that was so close That was close Sanji Oh Valorant Right That's the entire Valorant Yeah It's kind of popular Oh shit I don't think I don't think that, bro.
I don't know, actually.
I don't know, because Vegeta...
He's so beta, too, so to say.
What?
What do you mean?
What the fucking takes care of Vegeta?
I want to believe in Vegeta.
Doki, please.
He is not beta.
He's got...
No!
he's he's a male wife he is he's a male wife he's a he is 100 a male way like both he's literally boba like literally takes care of him like a like a chia pet no i honestly i think it's still valorant i think it's valorant too he's just he's a short king but she doesn't lose
I only would not say Vegeta because guys just don't get as big of numbers on here.
I'm so cute.
Cooking Vegeta.
Jobbed again.
Vegeta has jobbed in so many times.
You can't self-insert as Vegeta because nobody could be him.
Because nobody can be the prince of all Saiyans, am I right?
It has to be The slander to my boy Vegeta It has to be I love what I love No I would I refuse No this is my No I refused I No You keep doing this You keep doing this You can't No no You keep doing this You just You see Sonic and you Instinctively push it!
I can't help it!
It's Sonic!
Charizard!
I can't help it!
Dengun Rampa.
There's so many characters in Dengun.
Okay, Dengun Rampa.
Okay, good.
Okay.
Look, I'm doing it.
I'm doing it.
I think it's still Viper.
I don't know that character.
That fake character.
I don't know that character either.
I can't help it.
I see so incinerore 100% I I've seen the way people react incinerore I feel like the incinerore right incinerore yeah maybe oh freaking Delta rune again they are apparently they are very cultured people that inhabit rule 34 and have daily updates I don't even know who that person is I'm just picking cuz persona yeah i've seen this character before but i don't know as if she's like popular popular try it oh she's popular popular what the is captain price from column i who is who is going to captain price oh apparently that is a okay i okay give me a second give me what are we what are we looking up here i need a dope oh my Don't look up,
don't...
What did you look up?
I'm looking up Captain Price.
Wait, what did you look up?
What did you see?
Why did you see?
Did you go to R34 and see?
Did you go?
Oh no, why did you search R34 in Google?
spooky google searches rule 34 captain price of course you're gonna see shit in because i was curious i was like who's doing this who's 30 who's doing cat who was uploading 334
what did you see bit what did you see what did you see
you know what they say curiosity kills the cat
mistakes were made today mistakes were made we were just we didn't know we didn't know I still think it's fucking monogatari we just didn't know we can do it we can get the 20 Shantae.
There's no way Haxiris is gonna be kidding through this.
I mean from Honkai?
I don't even know if she's popular.
I don't know.
Every last time we draw.
It has to be.
No!
By nine.
Marie Rose.
Marie Rose, yeah.
I mean a hundred easy.
How does she have less?
Did you see that she has less than?
Don't she has less than I'm sick of seeing I want to try.
I never want to see this fucker again.
No, but the other guy...
Oh my god, Kirito for the self-insome.
But the other guy had less...
She had less than Captain Price.
Like, I don't understand.
Why did she have less than other person?
Who is it?
Who had less?
The other girl that was against Marie Rose.
She had 144, but Captain Price...
price out of 334 i don't understand what is captain it's great skull it's okay yeah it was not i think kirito is i think kirito just has a lot of self-insert i think marine was more popular yeah it was the other one not pearl but the other girl yeah that had more sakura only because she's a main character like you might hate her but oh oh there's There's not enough V superfans.
Yeah, I was going to say there's not enough...
Oh!
Just kidding.
I was going to say...
Oh, Steinsgate, though.
This one's hard.
Probably Steinsgate.
I just say...
Oh.
Never mind.
Hinata?
Oh, not Hinata?
Oh, my God!
I'm not even used to the bathroom after that.
I'm quitting this game.
Did she leave?
guys i don't want to play this anymore what the hell you mean why is it because he's inserted in more things where he could get with sakura he could get with hina no he could get with sazke
oh my god
challenge we can try that probably oh when stokey comes back i'll ask her i'm tired of this i'm tired of this why are you tired people were saying maybe we should try doing the daily challenge to the end oh the daily yeah we'll do it we'll do at the end yeah rainbow dash rainbow dash it has to be like i'm surprised dash clears the entire franchise oh no this is oh and what do you mean the what do you mean the chipmunks there's no way are you kidding me there how how explain explain oh well it's their chipmunks yes and and that's appealing to somebody and who is the somebody could you care to explain okay starts with a d
Okie bird
There's no way there's no way Do you are you gonna Are you you know what we're only at two It doesn't matter It doesn't matter All in on Alvin and the chick Oh yeah yeah yeah yeah Did you yeah yeah Yeah Alvin and chick books Oh 1,062 The fact that there's a thousand Everybody check Doki's IP address Oh my IP address You're the one that was saying one boasting all of it yeah yeah me yeah the smurfs smurfette yeah smurfette alone oh my god there's so much there's must be a lot oh i think jean jean gray yeah but does jean gray have the the blue body of smurfette though i've heard i've heard her name before and i know nothing about the x-men oh she's the the love interest of uh scott the got the cyclops guy oh i think she's really yeah oh it was yeah mercy i don't even need to see who's on the other side oh oh shoot what was metroid again i don't remember actually i do need to see who's on the other side phone a friend phone a chat phone a chat guys we have to end stream eventually we one
more Metroid was 26k said somebody okay nice good job that's good job team good job team this is a team effort good job class all around class all around it's good job Metroid Metroid there's no way Robin I know Robin's popular though I feel like Robin just because I think Robin yeah like the whole franchise there's not a lot of women in remote attention there's Captain Price was 344.
You are still on Captain Price?
Because I'm saying
exactly how many he had.
That's how I was, it was trauma.
It's ingrained in my head.
I think, I don't know actually, I have no idea.
I think Veroni Kenshin.
But it's fate though.
Yeah, but I've never heard of her.
Oh, oh, you're right.
That's good.
If you never heard of
Who's that over there?
You clear her, right?
That would be so sad if you don't.
You're like, I don't even know where and she beats you.
That would be so sad.
I don't know.
Oh, shit.
400 and 408.
I'm sorry, but...
I can't wait to get through.
I don't think you win.
I can't win against the Goomba!
I mean, look at him.
Is he...
I'm sorry.
I think the Goomba clears you, Min.
Oh, by a lot, too.
There's a lot of Goomba.
I mean, look at his shape.
I know.
I'm just saying the shape alone makes it.
The matchup of the century.
I get it.
I understand.
Yeah, the Goomba...
Against any other character, though, like, it has to be a Goomba.
And it's like, we never got it before, dude.
The very first time the Goomba shows up, it was your matchup.
That's crazy.
Maybe I should draw myself more like a Goomba.
These people will find me more appealing.
I admit it to all the Goomba drawings on the side.
Like, he can be, like, the guy that's just there.
model.
Yes, and they can add you to the Goomba category.
They'll have to add Goomba to your tag.
Yeah.
I mean, I already have one tooth, one bang tooth.
I can have two going up.
For Halloween, you should dress up like a Goomba.
Okay, that is going to be so sexy.
I beat Captain Bryce.
You know how I have Garfield?
You can have Goomba.
Wait, we haven't gotten Garfield yet.
We got Goomba, but now we got Dead Company.
Yikes.
Okay, this is your field of interest, so I...
Leave it to you.
Okay, this is hard.
Because...
Zenyano's not that popular, but...
I think...
But then SFM videos.
Also, I don't know why.
He's barking.
I don't know why he's, like, faked something.
I don't know.
Oh, I...
feel like Goomba.
I don't know.
The SMM videos might include Zenyata too.
That's the thing.
We are at 11.
Oh, this is risky.
Oh, this is, oh, yeah.
It's always the SMM videos that, it's always the SMM videos that basically clutches it up, but I think I'm gonna go with Goomba.
I think it's Goomba.
Oh, thank God.
160.
Yeah, you got more than Zenyata.
I got more than Zenyata, Buren.
Yeah, like, David versus Goliath right here.
Did you know who this is?
She is a popular character but i still think it's free rune yeah i was gonna say if you're in just from just fearin alone yeah it has to be led right but he's also not written yeah it's not written that's the thing but miku had like what 20k or something like that i feel like i want to feel like it's len because vocaloid yeah but but he's also a guy yeah exactly exactly he's awful a guy He's also a guy.
Oh, thank God.
Just barely.
Rink it.
All I'm saying is that you gotta have a specific IQ to understand this franchise.
So I don't know.
Yeah, I have a particular IQ.
But you don't have to have an IQ to be horny.
I want to feel like it's Rink and Morty just because the show is so popular.
But I don't know.
I mean I guess the the mom I I don't know there's the there's I don't know I mean Pickle Rick was pretty good No it wasn't Pickle Rick was pretty good I like it's a classic though it is a classic I think since this site is more western we gotta go Rick and Morty your final answer.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my.
It was Rick and Morty.
I remember.
Courage did not clear.
Yeah, Courage did not clear.
Oh, my God.
There's no way.
Like, everyone went crazy.
Oh, Shy Guy.
Look, the Goomba had 2K.
So there's no way Shy Guy clears over Goomba.
There's no.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, cool.
The Shy Guy is 1,100.
greekul she's in two games so she has two different outfits and she's also well i guess that i don't know if they would count we're at 19 if we get this right we end the pressure is on this is this is the this is it if we get this we are freed oh no oh no no no no i don't know This is a game winning shot.
We're on overtime, man.
We're on overtime.
The ball is in your hand.
You have a three-point.
You have a two-point.
You got a penalty shot right here.
I don't know, though.
I don't know either.
And chat is also toward.
I have no idea.
Chat doesn't know.
Wait, why don't we let chat decide?
We put up a poll.
Yeah, but then they're going to vote.
the wrong answer because he wanted us to keep going you're right you're going to so sabotage us
my heart says riku
what do you think what do you think doki i'm like anime women that's like that's all i think but like i don't know this character in final fantasy because i don't play final fantasy she's in final fantasy 10 and 10 2.
oh i played She's in Kingdom Hearts.
Oh, is she the one with, like, all the hair accessories and stuff like?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I remember her.
Fuck, but is she popular enough?
I don't know.
Oh, my God.
Sephiroth is a man, though.
Someone says, Sephiroth only had 1,500.
He had the man deep up.
I mean, Vegeta job.
Do you remember that, guys?
Vegeta lost again.
Oh, I don't know.
She is really popular, but, like, I don't know.
We don't do a poll.
We know yourself that sabotages.
You want us to keep going.
This is it.
This is the game-winning shot.
Oh, my God.
I don't know.
Because Shy Guy has a thousand hundred.
Why does Shy Guy have so much?
What is he doing?
Apparently, there's also a girl version of Shy Guy.
Oh, of course there is.
There's always a girl version.
We can't do girl biases because there's a shy girl, but apparently so-called shy guy.
No, no, I don't know.
Oh, I don't know.
I want to say Riku.
Riku?
All right.
Final answer.
Yeah.
Show it, show it.
Scroll up, scroll up.
We did it!
All right, we do until we...
lose let's see how long okay oh raising rising of shield here i think it's the rising of the shield hero character no we lost okay we did we're just a daily challenge yeah what's the daily challenge welcome 10 rounds you'll play exactly 10 rounds of tag comparisons new tag each round each round features two completely new tags click on tag you think has more posts track your progress oh apparently everything is the same okay well it's ash obviously i think it's ash yeah okay it was not ash 344 and diana had i don't remember but i know captain price 344 but go with captain price then if you're so sure no but diana might have more we don't i don't I don't know how much Diana has.
Oh, wait.
Scroll down a little.
Scroll down.
Oh, yeah, here.
There you go.
Yeah.
Diana.
Guys, which one?
Captain Price.
There's no way it's Captain Price.
Okay, Captain Price.
Oh, my God.
Someone uploaded.
There's no.
Okay, he was zero.
Someone uploaded.
say that someone uploaded three more pictures for Captain Price while we were playing this game because it was not 337 it went the last time who did this who did this who did this who added who did this who did this who did this who did this why did you include my dog into this picture
the dog in the text
I think it's you it's me?
Yeah, I think it's you.
Yeah.
But like I feel, is it?
Yeah, I think it's you.
Is it real?
Okay, okay, we'll go with me.
Oh yeah, no.
Oh, nice.
Wait, did you see the number?
Nice.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
Alphys, maybe.
Susie had like a lot But Alphys she did have a lot But Alphys is like You're just going to motivate your whist To upload more down rule 34 now That's okay I don't need it Like we must try harder now See that's what I'm saying The less you show The least bit offended The less you show The more you get
Susie's a main character or maybe Susie then A lot of people Like Alphys but maybe Susie Go with Susie Susie Oh Cause she's newer Jess Better Dr. Eggman Bro Okay but bro Check out I mean Look at Dr. Eggman though He's a built I honestly think it's Dr. Eggman.
I feel like it'd be, I don't know, because it's Disney, too.
But it's Sonic.
You're going against.
Sonic, remember?
It is Sonic.
Yeah, always pick Sonic.
Eggman clears.
There's no way.
There's no way!
Okay, Jasmine apparently did some, had something for people.
I don't know why.
Maybe she was a lot of childhood crushes, you know.
That's true.
Like, who was it?
That was your childhood crush?
you didn't oh jenny yeah yeah and then you never believed in jenny i know i should have isn't miss forage i feel like miss fortune look at her look at it okay nice nice we're doing it we're too oh i think it's me yeah has to be me for i know i know rosie didn't have that many no don't do it don't do it i just stormed the albatross why do we we have seen this guy maybe ten times
eventually he'll win eventually but not right now actually no i don't think i'll pick megumi i mean gojo's a main character yeah but gojo didn't even get a lot and he had like one k or something i don't think if it stormed the albatross i will pull my hair out Are you ready?
It can't be it!
It can't be!
Oh thank god!
Imagine it was Stormy Albatross.
We were playing Stormy Albatross fans!
We're hot in there!
Why are we a dying species?
I don't understand.
You don't even know it!
As a new Storm fan, I demand more.
She's in the roll 30 port tag.
Android Android 18.
And has to be 18, though.
I feel like it's Android 18.
She's like one.
Yeah, one of the OG.
She helped everyone learn about Goon.
She was the Kickstarter of the Goon Bellion.
She was the trigger finger.
Yay!
Share your score.
Share your score with Amber.
Yeah, I'll do it.
I'll let you share my score.
Let me go.
Yeah, share your score.
Let me hide my screen real quick and share my score.
Score, copy, the clipboard.
Wait, what?
Oh, I guess you go and paste it like on your screen.
Like this, look.
I'll tweet that out.
Now it looks like Wordle.
Yeah.
Here we go.
8 out of 10.
Not bad.
No, not bad.
We did pretty well.
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah.
Go, go!
Oh my god, wait.
No, I used to watch stuff for both of these kids.
It's so hard to pick because both of these yet isn't it?
I want to believe in Minna.
I want to believe in Minna too.
Even though Goku's my husband.
Oh!
Barely!
I can't believe you didn't believe in your husband like this.
Nobody does.
Nobody believes it.
Life doesn't believe it.
Yeah, that's you.
Can't be.
Goku doesn't lose.
Finally.
How does Goku have so many in Navajin?
Because Goku's always winning.
What do you mean?
Because the ladies will pick Goku.
To be fair, it's like way closer.
than I thought it was going to be.
Yeah, me too.
I was like, whoa.
Goku always solos.
That was fun.
I had a great time.
Yeah.
Let me turn off the classical music now.
Aw.
I was feeling so sophisticated.
You know, while we were looking through, while we were looking through Rule 34, oh my, that was a fun time, though.
That was fun, yeah.
I admit went in with I guess like blindly not knowing what we're gonna be doing no at all yeah um but we learned a lot about each other today um maybe a little bit too much but that's okay it was indeed a very very wild ride learned a lot of people's interests as well.
Captain Price.
Now you have to play Call of Duty.
I already do play Call of Duty.
What do you mean?
Yeah, I've streamed some of Call of Duty games, but I don't know who the fuck Captain Price is.
Who the fuck?
I just want to know.
Who are the two fans of Captain Price that's uploaded 337?
Captain Price.
artworks of him now because it was 34 last time so someone found three more images to put in how do you not know who he is he's been in he appears in everything since before how many call of duty games are there i have no idea he's in one two three four five six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen games in oh there's 13 games yeah he was right every year there's no way he's he was in the very first game there's no way he's that popular he was in call of duty four that's what he started oh okay i can't even remember who plays what bro he's just look at him he's so generic what does he
He doesn't look ready to fight.
Where's your helmet, soldier?
Soldier, why are you fishing?
We have a war to go to.
Okay, he also goes by Bravo 6, Bravo 1, prisoner number 627, Black Viking, dollar sign,
B02, 9051210, Old Man and Classic Price.
Classic Price.
His name is John Price.
No.
He gave me this first name's not Captain.
He's literally the meme.
John.
John Meem.
John of Duty.
It's him.
Oh my God.
We got him.
John of Duty.
Oh my God.
I can't believe it.
Fucking Captain Price.
I can't believe he was in the God.
goddamn daily challenge.
They added him for you.
Yeah, like we gotta put him in.
Swap someone out right now.
We gotta put Captain Price in.
The devs are watching.
There's no way.
There's no way that you and I were in it and then also it.
It's an inside.
This was an inside job.
This is an inside job.
Yeah.
They knew.
His stream sniping us.
That's why they kept giving us freebies And then also, yeah, Storm the Albatross The Storm the Albatross
One day One day Storm will The Storm the Albatross will clear I believe in him I am the new fan A new discoverer Of Storm the Albatross I understand Apparently not Because there's still 300 other people I'm a new fan I understand now You have welcomed me with open arms Albatross the run killer
One day One day he'll clear Captain Price I believe in him I believe in Storm He can do it He'll make the Sonic fandom proud oh that was really really fun i honestly i did not expect how the stream was gonna go it exceeded all my expectations and it um it was something it was something it really it really was it was something it was a journey yeah i hope you all learned a lot today yeah i learned a lot too I learned a lot about the gooner history.
What?
Yeah.
Wow.
I guess.
Oh, I guess because, like, why newer things have more is because more and more people are accepting the gooner way.
And they're not scared anymore.
They're not scared.
They're not scared anymore.
We accept your ways.
We're all, like, so accepting now.
you're all free the goons you're free, you're cringe and you're free yay yay, you're horny and you're free
I love when like, when we both look on the side it looks like we're like, yo, check this out bro bro, check this out what are you showing me on there don't you?
no, no, no, I swear it gets good stop showing me, cast and prize I don't want to know.
You want to see the story of the Albatross?
Look at this.
I don't want to see it anymore.
I don't want to.
Oh, all right.
We're going to call it here, guys.
We, okay.
This was good.
This was fun.
That was fun, everyone.
We hope you all enjoyed today's stream.
And we hope you all recover from, from, I don't know, trauma, if there was any.
I have trauma.
Yeah, from PDR.
PTSD
Yeah, I'm so happy we didn't get Garfield.
Thank God you you would have had to change Why didn't you wear Garfield today?
Because why should I why would I be wearing Garfield?
Don't keep promise she would wear Garfield today.
That is not true.
She is that is not true What do you okay?
No, man, what do you have?
What's with you and Garfield?
Huh?
What is it?
We were literally at a hentai club together.
Don't lie.
You see, we should, we should make a new club.
You can be the vice president of the Garfield Club.
Because, do you say we're, we're cringe and free now?
Yeah!
shouldn't be scared anymore the two only the two members of the cartfield head tie club
i hope we don't get a c synthesis oh my god if we have enough members we might uh what we could do outings no no no no we're not gonna we're not gonna do outings i'm saying if we have enough members, Jim Davis might notice us.
It'll be like the most popular Garfield group online.
And then maybe PopBase will make a tweet about us.
Maybe they'll be like, do not join.
They give you, they send you a link to Jenny, my grandpa.
And it gives you a virus.
I think if I ever did a cease and desist from Jim Davis, I think that's the greatest honor.
I'll have a signature from Jim.
I'll have a free autograph from Jim Davis.
You should, like, make it into merch.
Yeah, I frame it.
It's a curfew on EdTech Club.
Put it on a t-shirt or something.
I got a cease and desist from Jim Davis.
And then like the back would be the front or the back would be the cease and desist.
And then the other side would be like, I got a cease and desist from Jim Davis for starting a Garfield Hentai Club.
Yeah.
Everyone would get it.
I know.
I think it would be a top seller too.
I think.
We should do it.
Imagine, oh my God, you know, any publicity is
then he'll know it as vtubers then he'll know what vtubers are you could send an apology video as your car fuel you're like I'm sorry I'm your biggest fan I love you and then he'll send another one because you're using the car fuel resemblance
then I'll have two autographs I'll have two
One for my office and one for my bedroom.
I'll have it framed.
Yeah, it'll be great.
Oh.
Anyway, thank you guys for coming.
We all enjoyed our time together.
Yes.
Hope we all learned something.
Did we enjoy your time?
We all enjoyed our time together.
Do you have any final words, Mint, before we couldn't call us out?
That's right.
I'm putting you on the spot.
That's like you're it.
Upload more...
The Captain Price?
No, I was going to say Albatross.
I'm sorry, if either one works.
Yeah.
More Albatross art, please.
More Albatross and Captain Price, please.
moral routine please all right as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around and get that blood flowing and if you stand for us to end the bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everyone bye guys